the whole music video the whole idea of
you haunting past lovers is just really
fun i'll be honest
are there people in this world that you
are their ghost story i have not seen
any of the exes
in a whole long time because i have been
married for almost 12 years now yeah but
i'm sure we've all got one you know i'm
sure every single person on this planet
just has somebody that kind of creeps
into their memory every once in a while
unfortunately when you look at somebody
who's become
a celebrity yeah it would be kind of
hard to escape
i'm not just saying me i'm saying any of
us
supposed to be right here if you're on
like magazine covers or whatever you're
like checking out the grocery store and
they're like there's an ex-girlfriend
again like on the cover of whatever
that'd be difficult i just want to watch
some football
why is your friend singing the opening
like what's happening
[Music]
are your kids at the point where they're
giving you honest feedback or do they
just love everything you do they'll
never be like i don't like that song but
they'll request things in the car and
sometimes they do request my songs so oh
this album crazy angels is probably
isaiah's favorite
[Music]
and they also request denim rhinestones
[Music]